foreign
ER welcome to how the light gets in
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
um so you have a YouTube channel its
name is Cosmic skeptic where did the
name come from and what does skepticism
mean to you
well I used to make videos under my own
name Alex O'Connor unfortunately it's
just a little clunky of a title there
there's a rather well-known Indie
singer-songwriter called Rex Orange
County whose real name is Alex O'Connor
that's his legal name and he recently
did an interview where he was asked why
do you want why do you go by the name
Rex Orange County and he said well
because you know Alex O'Connor is such a
such a terrible name you can never style
yourself with that you never sell any
records and multiple people sent it to
me and I I they thought I'd be angry but
I was like this is exactly why I had to
come up with a pseudonym
um I'd seen someone that I knew who was
making music uh and and using the word
Cosmic in there in their title and I
just thought it was kind of a cool word
while I was looking for a YouTube name
and there was a there was already a
broad community of YouTubers who are
using this skeptic you know addendum
something skeptic and so it kind of came
naturally after that but for a time I
can of being Cosmic critic which is
it's it's horrid it makes me kind of
want to throw up in my mouth when I
think about how close I came to cooling
the channel that but it's a weird name I
I don't much like having a username as
my sort of business title and my my how
I'm introduced in talks and stuff like
this William Lane Craig a wonderful
philosopher of religion who I was very
lucky to have on my podcast I only
learned after the fact that he nearly
turned me down because my name was
Cosmic skeptic because he thought that I
was some kind of global skeptic a
skeptic about truth you know sort of a
skeptic of cosmic proportions which is
an understandable inference for him to
make but this is what I'm saying it kind
of puts people off but kind of came out
of that the skeptic
idea is generally used more colloquially
on the online space skepticism in
philosophy is often defined quite
specifically there are different kinds
of skepticism and it generally implies a
kind of questioning Spirit towards the
axioms that we use to build our World
Views and and our inability to
epistemically justify a lot of those
axioms and so we can't know they're true
and this is skepticism the kind of
project that Descartes famously partook
in
colloquially it generally means
something more like questioning your
beliefs at the surface level digging a
bit deeper than usual to see if they can
see if they really resonate with your
fundamental principles and that's the
kind of skepticism that I guess I was
promoting when I started the channel you
mentioned that there's this kind of
online YouTube community that
has skeptic kind of connotations on it
in its presentation and there's often a
kind of
um Affinity with like right-wing
politics with those channels it's
skepticism of this kind of colloquial
kind as you said somehow kind of
inherently connected to more
conservative views
well there seemed to have been
generations of atheist YouTube let's say
and the the skeptic Community is often
thought of as kind of the same thing as
the atheist community and and now it
kind of is a lot of the more modern
Skeptics and people who you would
include in the skeptic Community aren't
just the people who call themselves
something skeptic it's a bit broader
than that these days I I think it's
actually the opposite I think at least
the atheist community that that I've
been kind of put in the group of
naturally the kind of people that I
consider my colleagues are
much more left-wing than right wing but
a sort of YouTube generation ago maybe
sort of just shy of a decade ago or so
you had the kind of people who were
doing the kind of things that we're
doing here which is making
critical response videos to religious
content and you're quite right that a
lot of the older generation of YouTube
Skeptics ended up on the right one of
the reasons for this might be that a lot
of the popular right-wing discourse on
YouTube consisted in the same kind of
style of attack or style of polemic
which is taking broad World Views that
are being put forward taking ideology
and just poking holes and it's it's a
it's an easy enough thing to do it's
it's much easier than presenting your
own worldview you take a worldview that
exists and you just say I'm not sure
about that I'm not sure about that I
don't think that follows and people
think you're very smart for doing it
because you're finding very clever ways
to to not so much poke the holes but
show where the holes exist and it's
easier to do that as a reactionary of
course it's it's reaction by trade and
so if we ask why these like channels
that focused on reacting to ideological
videos in the kind of religious field
ended up becoming reactionaries well I
mean it's almost to tautology it seems
fairly natural to me
more and more now when people try to
make skeptical content I certainly try
to do this myself I I try to avoid doing
that kind of content so much anymore
these days we're making well at least
I'm trying to make podcasts I'm giving
talks I'm making broad videos where I
put forward my own views as a totality
which I think stops me from the
temptation of of getting into that field
I think one of the other reasons is that
a lot of the time people who are doing
religious criticism online certainly the
the older generation of YouTube atheist
people
they probably fell into it through
argument it wasn't a love of philosophy
or a love of philosophy of religion but
a love of argument in general and they
found that the religious debate is a
really fun one so they they make a video
being like well the Bible isn't 100
accurate because we have evolutionary
science and people think wow that was
really entertaining and so they
subscribe and they think I better talk
about this and so they get known for
talking about this kind of stuff and
then somebody asks them how they ground
their ethical worldview
and they think oh well I I don't know
because I'm not a philosopher I I this
isn't how I got into it and so they
think well I better have something to
say so they start kind of trying and it
doesn't really work and they think they
basically like run out of places to go
so it's like well what can I do now well
I'm I'm not a philosopher I'm a
reactionary and where's the best place
to be a reactionary at the moment it's
in the online conservatives face so they
naturally tend towards it I think that's
very interesting because it seems like
it has absolutely nothing to do with the
content of the beliefs that they have
because a lot of these channels were
originally from people in North America
where obviously the rights is more
associated with religion and kind of you
know beliefs and God and so on but it
sounds like these people just wanted to
critique for critique's sake it wasn't
really about what the content of the
critique was yeah I think it's about the
notion of ideology if you look at
traditional left-wing criticism liberal
criticism you had a kind of state
ideology nationalistic ideology that the
liberal left was was poking holes in you
know this was the natural the natural
approach they were the the reactors
there seems to have been a switch in the
way that the dialect is understood now
that the ideologues are now the leftists
and it's the the right wing that is
poking holes in the ideology rather than
it being the other way around and so
maybe that might explain why we have the
strange shift from religious criticism
being a left-wing thing to being a
right-wing thing because maybe it's
actually just about poking hole in
ideology in general and that's something
that seems to have switched from the
right to the left and so it makes sense
that these these people do as well it's
the kind of person who
as you say it's not interested in the
content but in the argument for
argument's sake which is fine it's a
hobby for some people like if you're
interested in having debate you can join
a debate club and they'll give you the
motion 10 minutes before you give the
speech and the fun is trying to defend
the position for the sake of Defending
it but if that's what you're into then I
you know don't style yourself as a as a
thinker who's got like ideas that they
really care about and want to put across
if that's not what you're doing
let's talk a little bit about skepticism
you're already alluded to the fact that
you aren't a global skeptic you don't
sort of question absolutely everything
in terms of the existence of Truth say
but how do you understand skepticism and
where do you see the limits because a
lot of people say that radical
skepticism is what leads people to
subscribe to say conspiracy theories or
kind of extreme questioning of the
status quo how do you see the balance
between a healthy kind of skepticism and
an extreme skepticism well I think like
half baked skepticism leads to this kind
of
conclusion because you question
everything but never actually look for
an answer on any of those things you
kind of question this and question that
and question that and you're left in
this kind of pit of agnosticism about
everything where you're completely
vulnerable to believe anything that's
put convincingly in front of you I think
you need to sort of focus on a
particular area that you're interested
in at the time and are skeptical of and
look for the answer this is again the
Cartesian project a lot of people style
Descartes as a as a skeptic
and he was methodologically but he
wasn't a skeptic in the way that people
often pain him out to be he didn't like
not think that we can ground our
epistemology he thought that we could
his only question was but well how do we
do that and so it's a methodological
tool that he uses he says well let's
throw it all out let's pretend it's
false and see if we can prove it true
again and he thinks he can do that he
thinks he he regains what he loses
um by by finding ways to ground truth
and this is the kind of skepticism that
I think we should be promoting and again
at a more surface level of not so much
question everything because you can't
know if it's true but there are certain
things that we we do seem reasonable in
believing are true but let's see if we
can trace the line of thought and make
sure we're confident in those beliefs of
course it can only go down to a certain
level but it depends on what the motive
is here is the motive getting a
philosophical truth or is the motive
trying to convince people to stop eating
animal products or something because in
the second case it's a lot easier to
just take some axiomatic thought that
someone has or maybe something that's
derived from an axiom a bit higher up
something like suffering is bad and then
have some skepticism about factory
farming you know is this causing more
suffering than you think it is is the
animals suffer in a way that is morally
significant and then you try to find the
answers and you have this line of
thought which justifies
veganism or something close to it but of
course you could still just question the
Axiom that that whole precipice was
built upon but then you're getting into
a kind of global skepticism which is not
something I shy away from I'm happy to
do it but as Hume famously talks about
induction similar to Descartes people
misunderstand him they think that Hume
said induction is false or something
like this he didn't he said of course
induction is true of course induction is
an accurate depiction of the world it's
just that we've got absolutely no way of
justifying it this is the kind of thing
I'm talking about when I say I'm not a
global skeptic it's not that I don't
question these things it's not that I'm
not interested in the question of
are there certain things that we just
have no justification for it's that I do
that but the belief that I'm questioning
are sometimes in the human spirit
like well of course this is true but I'm
interested in finding out whether we can
epistemically warrant that that belief
and what happens if we if we find out
that we don't have justification for our
beliefs as in the case of induction Hume
solution was well we just have to carry
on philosophy you know has its limits we
then go on and Lead Our Lives
do you find that answer satisfying or
does it leave a bit of a air of futility
of the exercise well we did this we
found that there's no ground but nothing
changes well
you know Hume doesn't just say well we
we kind of just have to believe in
induction in the sense of
well we better do that because if we
don't we're going to run into problems
but no we have to like it's impossible
to doubt it if you doubted induction to
the extent that would be reasonably
justifiable if Hume is correct I'd have
if I wanted to continue having this
conversation with you I have no more
reason to you know try to vibrate my my
vocal cords than I do to pour a bottle
of water over my head and think it'll
have the same result there's just that
humans just do Hume describes the
disgust and he says that this is like
the answer but it's not an answer to the
it's an answer to the skeptical doubts
as he frames it in the in the inquiry
but it's not the kind of answer that
that justifies induction or solves the
problem it's an answer of the kind or
what do we do given this it's the kind
of answer that's given at the end of
Ecclesiastes when you have this list of
nihilistic ramblings and the conclusion
of the matter is fear God and follow his
Commandments that's not an answer to
Nile ISM in the sense of showing why
it's false or showing if it's Justified
or not it's a practical answer to what
do we do given this sorry State of
Affairs and given the sorry State of
Affairs of not being able to justify
induction
it doesn't actually matter in terms of
our beliefs because it's not like well
maybe we should just withhold belief in
it it's like good luck you're not going
to be able to do that and you're left in
a fairly dissatisfactory state
philosophically that you can't justify
it but practically it makes no
difference because you're never going to
be able to abandon that belief so Hume
famously kind of argued that you know
reason has its limits when it comes to
motivating moral Behavior how do you see
that applying to the case of
vegetarianism is reason really not
strong enough to convince people of
moving away from a meat-eating diet
do the passions how to get involved more
the emotions how did how did you change
your view on this and becoming
increasingly skeptical of the
distinction between thinking and feeling
um at least in most scenarios what's
being styled is thinking is actually a
form of feeling or belongs in the
category of emotive expression kind of
like emotivism about ethics but
emotivism about even
philosophy in general even non-emotive
statements such that when we say well we
have a reasonable belief that we should
be vegan or something like this but must
it be the slave of the passions must
there be some other motivating factor
that you kind of tack onto it but it's
possible that what we're describing is
reason is actually reason in the sense
of motivation like the reason to get out
of bed or the reason that I go vegan or
something like this I mean for me I read
animal Liberation by Peter Singer and
I'm not very impressed by his meta
ethics but I was very impressed with his
highlighting of ethical inconsistencies
I'm very grateful to Peter singer for
the the contribution he's made to the
alleviation of the suffering of animals
but I don't think he's particularly
impressive on the philosophy I think he
was just like the only guy that was
doing it it's it's more the fact that he
put it on the table that I think makes
him such a unique and useful and
wonderful philosopher rather than the
actual content of the belief
um as I say I think his meta-ethical
view doesn't work I kind of can't make
heads or tails of it in fact what are
you what are you um unconvinced by what
what aspect of singers met ethics
specifically
when he the the biggest problem for
objectifying utilitarianism is going
from the intuitive and seemingly
self-evident notion that a person's
pleasure is good for them
depends how exactly what you mean by
good but at least it's it's enjoyed by
them or is beneficial to them something
of this sort
utilitarianism requires that because my
pleasure is good to me I'm somehow
committed to the view that pleasure is
good in general regardless to its
attached to singer quite specifically
says well the fact that my pleasure is
good for me is essentially some kind of
demonstration that pleasure is good I
just think that's a that's a that's a
jump this is where the the is ought is
smuggled in as it must be somewhere and
you people anybody who claims to
objectify ethics generally is is
smuggling it in some people do it better
than worse Sam Harris is an example of
somebody who just it makes a comic
attempt at trying to to get away from
Humes doomed is ought notion as Sam
Harris describes it but very clearly
smuggles it in
um smuggled in this jump in other words
uh this is the problem of getting
normativity from simply looking at the
facts yeah which of course is famously
attributed as a thought to David Hume
um but I mean to answer your question I
I read Peter Singer and as I say I'm
unimpressed by his meta ethics but
you have you're confronted here with
with this reality of animal suffering
and
of course I'm kind of motivated by
reason in a sense there's like a a
consistency case to be made I've got
like a descriptive inconsistency with
how I view dogs versus pigs or something
like this but of course the thing that
finally causes someone to change is
going to be something that's that's more
motivational that belongs more in the
emotive framework but like if you're in
like an ethical emotivist then the
difference between ethical reasoning and
the motivation for ethical action just
become the same thing because ethics is
itself an expression of emotion and so
it doesn't make sense to talk about
non-motivating ethical claims which is
why of course David Hume is thought to
preempt non-cognitivism and emotivism
because he
accepts this premise that moral claims
are intrinsically motivating are you
saying that it doesn't make sense to say
that I'm rationally convinced that I
should do X but because I'm not
emotionally invested in it that's what
explains my kind of lack of action on
the basis of my sort of having arrived
at a conclusion
just by following a kind of argument
it's it's possible that people are
actually
not quite in tune with their own
thoughts or desires they'll kind of
think that they desire something but
their actions will betray them
um so there's a complication by the fact
that people aren't always actually
don't don't have direct access to the to
their deepest motivations and aren't
always aware of all the factors in play
but it's a big ethical problem how do we
how do we deal with somebody who is
convinced rationally of an ethical
position but not motivated to act in
accordance with it and of course there
are just a few different ways to explain
this one is to say Well they're just not
convinced ethically speaking because to
be ethically convinced if something is
to be motivated to do it that's what
ethics essentially is what is it that
makes ethics different from
propositional thinking what is the ought
and the is distinction what is the
difference it must be that the ought has
some normative force it has something
some kind of call to action embedded
into its nature such that if you don't
have that call to action if you don't
have that normative force in the belief
you you just don't have the ethical
belief you just kind of claim that you
do or think that you do but
misunderstand the position that the
other person's actually trying to get
you to become convinced do you think
that's do you think that's likely I mean
how would we expect explain um say
feeling guilty for failing to live up to
a moral standards so say I have I know
that I you know I should stop eating
meat and yet I kind of failed to do so
and it's not like I I think that's fine
I think that there's something I've done
wrong here and sure but feel bad about
it if if you feel bad about it that is
the motivation to act in accordance with
it the motivation won't necessarily be
strong enough to actually make you act
in accordance with it the motivation is
still there
it's just too weak to actually overcome
maybe inhibitions or maybe to overcome
other motivating factors that are at
play like the motivation that you have
to towards convenience or taste pleasure
or something like this and it could just
be a fact that
one motivation is stronger than the
other but the motivation is still there
so this wouldn't be a case of somebody
who says if somebody says to me well I'm
convinced of the vegan position but you
know I'm not motivated to act in
accordance with it but I just feel so
bad when I when I when I eat meat it's
like well actually there is some
motivation in there then it's just
motivation isn't strong enough to compel
your action so what do you think is the
best way as it were to not just convince
people of why it's morally problematic
to eat animals or consume other animal
products but to actually change their
behavior is it going to be through
reasons is it going to be through
someone reading a philosophy book or is
it going to be something else
it was for me but I mean to it's a
rather boring answer to any question but
like it depends right it depends on the
person
if so myself like I kind of pride myself
on on consistency and having a world
view that I can present and defend and
this kind of thing it's like my job to
talk about philosophy and arguments and
stuff and so the motivating factor that
exists Within Me is a motivation towards
things like consistency and coherency of
my worldview and honesty and this kind
of thing and so when I read just a
reasonable case as it were just just
Peter saying as animal Liberation and I
think to myself well this is quite
compelling and maybe I don't have a
motivational force in terms of feeling
sorry for animals and wanting to to save
them because I just are the poor animals
but maybe I've got this motivating force
towards like consistency philosophical
consistency and that's the motivation
that means that for me for a person like
me just reading the book is enough to
make me want to go vegan because I have
this desire towards consistency in some
ways quite a selfish kind of drive here
yes just want to not fall into cognitive
dissonance as it kind of is with I mean
famously a lot of people deny the
existence of altruism altogether and
that's the kind of line of thought I
think you're getting it there and it may
well be true but of course some people
demonstrably will be able to kind of
read an argument that they find
compelling but as you say they're just
not motivated to act and so for such
people
the argument would be different that
wait maybe you don't even make an
argument maybe you give them an
experience maybe you take them to a
factory farm or show them footage or
something like this it's much the same
as religious experience actually it's
it's a good example because I think this
is just how all beliefs are formed in in
essence
um there's going to be some kind of
motivational aspect this is why I say
I'm
suspicious of the distinction between
thinking and feeling because I think
there's thinking lurking at the bottom
there um at the bottom there somewhere
religion is a great example
I've never met a person who took on
religious faith purely because they read
a syllogism somewhere they were looking
in a book and they see an argument and
they think oh that's convincing and
immediately you know drop to their knees
and accept the existence of almighty God
it's it's so much more experiential I
mean the only example I can think of off
the top of my head is Anthony flew who
claims that he just kind of looked at
the biological data became convinced
that Free Will exists did also and then
thought oh well God must exist but I
feel as though there was more going on
there
um I was told by Andrew copson uh who is
a humanist in the in the UK who knew
Anthony flew that before he died he
seemed to kind of
seem to change you seem to be a
different person to who he was before
and copson was like disappointed because
he liked the atheist Anthony flew
because he's an atheist still but he
said it wasn't just like you've got this
guy who read an argument and just
thought okay fair enough it's like he
changed as a person I think there's
usually something so much deeper and
more experiential going on when it comes
to the formation of beliefs so even even
for the person who says no no that's not
me I know most people are convinced by
experience but I'm convinced by reason
alone I think there's still a motivating
factor to do with some kind of
a pleasurable emotive State coming about
as the result of being able to say that
you're consistent or being consistent
you just enjoy consistency and and
honesty and coherence it's still that's
still feeling that's still a
motivational aspect that undercut that
undermines no still wrong under gerds
let's say all of this reasonable
thinking you you brought up this kind of
parallel between religious faith and and
vegetarianism or veganism I was going to
ask you about how you see the connection
between philosophical theism which
relies on thinking about Arguments for
the existence of God and then religion
as we see it for the most part sort of
practice which is not really based on
arguments at all so if we're going to
draw this parallel with veganism are we
going to have to create institutions
that somehow compare to religion in
order to get more people on board if
arguments alone are not really going to
do it well people who already caricature
many ideologies is doing this they'll
tell you veganism is a new religion
which I I really hate when people get
caught up in the pedantry of the exact
words that are being used when someone
says veganism is a religion it's very
easy for me to say that's not what a
religion is there's a strict definition
but it's like look I know what they're
driving at okay like sure I could be a
parent and quibble with the terms but I
know what they're getting a metaphor
yeah and really I think they're getting
it something like the lurking presence
of Dogma which is the thing that makes
religion Bad Religion bad because dogma
and a lot of like the the vegan
Community will rely on on dogma and they
can be good dogmas and bad dogmas but
it's still Dogma if it's just a
principle that's just believed without
question and there'll be a lot of vegans
in the world who think
I won't eat animal products and that's
the principle for me it's like reducing
animal suffering as much as I can but
for some people you'll say well what if
this animal doesn't suffer is it okay to
you know eat their products and they'll
still just say no no it's still wrong
and they won't really be able to give
you a convincing reason why
and that to me seems like a red flag for
dogma and so when someone says veganism
is a religion I think they're driving a
tendency towards this kind of thing but
this exists in
any ideological movement or any cause
there will be dogmatic elements because
not everybody has the time to constantly
be pulling things down to the first
principles they have to rely on some
kind of dogma and so we see this
naturally happen we see people start to
kind of engage in say like a vegan
lifestyle you get like a vegan festivals
and stuff where sure you have speakers
and they're trying to engage and give
people arguments but that's only half
the reason it exists it exists for the
sake of community people like getting
together and sort of reaffirming the
fact that we're all kind of living this
life and it's kind of a validating
experience to know that this this
motivation you have to live in a
particular way isn't unique to you and
so it just it just happens naturally I
don't think we necessarily kind of need
to to do it but you'll see in any
movement people
say things like yeah we need to do this
we need to make sure we're fostering a
community we need to be strong together
we need to have protests and show our
solidarity and this this kind of thing
it's like
yeah I just I just think it does happen
naturally and I think it's such a boring
conversation when somebody
tries to say veganism is a religion or
something like this I think there's just
so much confusion in the terms going on
there it's like I know what you're
driving at and and what it is that
you're driving at is probably true but
for that that's the reason why the fact
that that is kind of accurate is why I
wouldn't be able to say that religion is
bad or veganism is bad it's like
sure the dogmatic elements of these
things are probably we could do without
them but this exists everywhere and so
to say religion is bad is is it would be
a bit strange so I'm happy to accept
that it has elements that are also
within religion but I'd say that both
are kind of okay saying religion is bad
it's like saying politics is bad sure
yeah but what does that mean it doesn't
get you very far right you mentioned
very briefly though the potential of
like engineering animals in some way
that they wouldn't feel suffering is
that
is that just a kind of philosophical
thought experiment or is that a
something that's on the table and what
do you make of that well I mean the
closest real life instantiation of this
is something like uh lab-grown meat as
people like to call it is this an animal
not really I mean it kind of has the
same biological data in the in the in
the meat which is what makes it so
strange and also promising uh but I'm
I'm fine with this if there's no
suffering involved I just kind of don't
see a problem might be a little more
complicated with human beings there
might be instances where even when
there's no suffering there's still
something wrong and I've tried to kind
of draw out that distinction why we can
justifiably
say that about humans but not non-humans
I made a video not long ago which upset
quite a lot of well I say quite a lot of
vegans a loud minority of My Vegan
audience when I said that animals
non-humans probably don't have a right
to life in the same way that humans do I
think there are kind of meaningful
distinctions to be made but with in the
animal context I think if there's no
suffering there's kind of no problem so
if there was some way to engineer these
beings that don't suffer I kind of think
that suffering or at least sentience
that is an apprehension of desirable and
undesirable states of experience
is is a prerequisite
for for
certainly for moral worth but also for
maybe Consciousness and certainly
conscious action in order to do
something you need to be sort of
motivated
to get to a point that you're not at
right now you need to say well I'm going
to do something because doing this will
get me to a desirable state that I'm not
at right now and so if you don't have
some conception of suffering which
broadly defined as like an experience
that is not wanted when experienced
there's no conscious action and so
you're talking about a rock you're
talking about a plant and in that case
yeah do we like with it
you mentioned earlier that you like to
be consistent in your views uh and kind
of make them coherent what's an area in
which you worry that you're in some kind
of cognitive dissonance and are you able
to sort of work on that to make your
beliefs a bit more coherent that's a
great question and I think it's going to
be a result of
sort of partial knowledge or confidence
so there might be areas that I know a
bit about maybe even more than average
because I'm into philosophy but don't
know enough about to to recognize that
I've got some inconsistencies Brewing it
could be that I'm inconsistent with My
Views towards non-human animals and
unborn fetuses for example there might I
might be just completely wrong on the
question of abortion
um I might be wrong on
questions of like economics
um it could be that like the real
critique of
the real critique that I'm driving at
when I talk about animal exploitation is
not so much
speciesism or something like that but
something more like capitalism
um such that by advocating for like
individual responsibility and change at
the level of the consumer I'm getting it
completely and exactly wrong because
this is exactly what these companies
want us to do to divert the blame from
them towards each other that could be
very wrong and recently I've been
exploring this idea thinking like is it
really the best response to the problem
of factory farming
hey let's just stop paying for this to
happen well maybe it's useful to do that
but that might not be like the answer
that's not like this is what we need to
do solve the problem it might be a more
let's say economic uh economically
informed position those are two examples
of places where I think there's there's
great potential for a lot of cognitive
dissonance but I hope I hope that that
can be remedied by further reflection
and conversations with intelligent
people who can show me where I'm going
wrong
um of course it's famously difficult to
recognize your own cognitive bias
and when you do it usually only lasts
for maybe like a few months or something
because you'll eventually change your
behaviors because of that motivating
factor so it's it's kind of hard to
point to an example where I think I'm
being cognitively dissonant here but
those are two plausible areas let's say
Alexa Connor Thank you very much
anytime
[Music]